YouTube toughens advert payment rules
oh this isn't you too now you've made me
really mad I'm so angry I challenge you
to factor
this announcement was trending on
Twitter hashtag YouTube Partner Program
youtubers were tweeting about it having
different opinions about it
controversial but the problem here is
that they're all wrong they're all wrong
I am the only one that is correct and if
you don't know what I'm talking about
let me just explain what that what is
happening basically YouTube came out and
said that surprised if you don't have
4,000 hours of watch time and a thousand
subscribers then you may not they didn't
exactly say that to be fair that's not
what they said but basically that was it
I like how they added at the end of the
statement
one of YouTube's core values is to
provide anyone the opportunity to earn
money from a thriving Channel
well now you're kind of saying one thing
together you can't do that now my
personal reaction to this was the first
instinct was okay so low and Paul filmed
a dead body
aimed smaller channels has to suffer how
does that make any sense it almost
sounds a bit similar to the ad pocalypse
where YouTube said that YouTube will no
longer allow creators to make money
until they reach 10,000 years big
creator messes up small channels suffer
I am so sorry about the ad pocalypse by
the way in case I haven't apologized
okay that was definitely me that
basically the reason why YouTube did
this is because they said phrasing it's
been clear over the last few months that
we need the right requirements and
better signals to identify channels that
have earned the right to run ads so
basically adding the bar to 10,000 users
is not enough for YouTube to make sure
that ads don't appear on videos that
they don't want it to and you know I
gotta give you two props for always
always anytime they announce anything
it's always such an
no one really knows what is going on and
it leads people to be confused and angry
and it's just the same thing every time
people are saying that so now if I'm not
in the partnership program it anymore
does that mean my videos aren't gonna
get recommended because they're not
earning revenue which each of us said no
to before but it's still kind of like is
that really true everyone seemed to
notice that differently people asking
like okay so now I'm not in the
partnership program anymore but what
about promotion and I can't schedule
uploads and losing all these benefits
what is that gonna mean for me and why
isn't that just a standard for anyone on
YouTube really
and also people who is not in the
partnership program anymore is asking
like a am I even gonna get paid I know
it's not a lot of money but am I gonna
get it right like probably you are but
the fact that these questions are an ass
answered it's always such a mess and
it's always so unnecessary a plus for
YouTube for always communicating so well
usually I find that YouTube isn't half
as evil as it seems to be doing these
things
it's just they can't seem to communicate
what it is they're actually doing and
then all these all this outrage comes in
and then they just pull back even more
now we have youtubers like keemstar so
now everyone's asking me well what
advice you have for small youtubers quit
you cannot make it in this game anymore
alright you're not going to make it
there is way too much competition
technically he's not wrong it's tough as
hell to be a youtuber these days but the
thing is it's always been hard YouTube
right now really pushes for watch time
unless you upload regularly and long
videos you are gonna suffer and I think
this is the real issue here this is what
you should be pissed off that put a lot
effort
and a really good channels don't get as
much exposure sure as they might deserve
because they don't fit in this quota and
it's always been like this channels come
and go on YouTube because they maybe fit
what the algorithm of you two
once and it's always there's been a wave
of people coming and going and that may
not deserve it or not because of this
YouTube has never turned a profit ever
since they they've done it and I think
they're really trying to change that but
if anything has shown that YouTube is
not a sustainable business model at
least no one's done it right yet and
that's why there's no competition to
YouTube just because it's so hard to
figure out even you have some YouTube
being so extremely successful with its
creator it's still not YouTube said that
he would Manly manually review all
relevant content by the end of March
because of this load and Paul thing they
said that they're gonna have more than
ten thousand workers reviewing Clips by
the end of 2018 that's a lot of workers
to review videos now here's my my main
point with this is this tweet that I saw
actually yesterday hahaha my sister used
to upload littlest petshop videos on
YouTube when she was nine and she
accidentally enabled ad revenue which
checked her adsense account yesterday
and she made 1,500 bucks turn up like
that's awesome I'm not gonna hit on that
I don't really have an issue with it
this is what you took trying to prevent
with this there's only so many ads on
YouTube it's not an infinite amount you
may be watching my channel sometimes and
there's no ads on it and that might be
because there was not enough ads to go
around it happens all the time that you
watch a video ads might be enabled but
they don't show up because there's not
enough to go around and I personally
think that stopping channels that are
coming out of nowhere just to upload
other people's contents like movies and
TV shows and that stuff cutting off
those people from making revenue and
taking away ads from channels that are
actually dedicated and offloading videos
it makes sense to me a lot of people get
really pissed because of the 4,000 hours
sing and I understand that that's
frustrating but people did the math and
essentially it comes down to like four
dollars four bucks a month or something
like
you arguing about that amount then maybe
you should ask yourself why are you
making YouTube videos it's always been
hard to be a small Channel always back
in the day YouTube used to have a manual
Partnership Program where you'd have to
apply and hopefully make it in and I
trust me you needed more than a thousand
subscribers to get into that if anything
it's clearly been too easy to put ads on
your channel and for bucks that doesn't
seem like you're looking at the bigger
picture you're complaining about that
personally I didn't make any revenue of
YouTube after making videos for a whole
year even more I think I had like twenty
five thousand subscribers and YouTube
wouldn't touch my channel they wouldn't
partner it and it was extremely
frustrating because I felt like I had I
had the chance to finally push in and
make it into a living but I couldn't but
it was way beyond four dollars I
understand that it's tough as hell to
get to a thousand subscribers and I
remember that seemed singing possible
but if you're looking at it as a way to
you should earn revenue before that so
you can get a few dollars that doesn't
to me doesn't really justify the the end
goal that they're trying to do here
blocking out people from uploading bad
content to YouTube or perhaps creating
another media system the only way I
could earn revenue back in the day was
to sign up with a network YouTube
wouldn't touch gaming channels and I
only did gaming channel back then and so
many youtubers not just me but just got
royally screwed over by networks taking
what like half of their revenue and
giving what back people don't talk about
that but four dollars oh no like yes
it's it's hard as hell to be a small
Channel I know that but it sure as hell
wasn't easier back in the day I think
it's great that YouTube is partnering
channels now and this is what they have
to do to make it happen and it seems
just fair to me even though it might
seem hard it's good a lot of people
saying well it's motivating maybe
getting a little bit of revenue and
seeing that you are earning something I
agree but
the ends doesn't justify the means and
at the end of the day I think it's sort
of a healthy approach that maybe you
shouldn't be earning revenue the very
first thing maybe that should be a goal
maybe you should be incentivized to work
on your subscribers and building an
audience first instead of earning
revenue first I understand that there's
more things to it but to me YouTube is
like a runner the fastest runner aligned
and then someone just tied his shoes
together and he fell and now he's
[ __ ] stole that joke from Brad but
it's so true since there's no
competition to youtube I think it's very
important that when bad things happen or
when they do bad things that we do stand
up against them I think it's important
that we do we are united as a community
but I also feel like this is not that
big a deal
save your energy and save your outrage
for something more important that will
have a bigger effect on the platform and
I hope that smaller channels don't get
discouraged by this keep working hard I
know it sucks it's always sucked
I do seen your channel subscribe and it
and it isn't impossible anyway I've been
going on for too long and that's just my
thought about it what do you think is
YouTube screwing over its creators
here's a poll and that's it for me for
now goodbye